Hey, listener, and welcome to Smart List. Before we get into this incredible episode, I want just a moment of your time to set the stage a little bit. Sean and Jason and I went on a smart list tour last year where we recorded 10 episodes live in front of thousands of our biggest fans from Brooklyn to Los Angeles. And guess what? Right now there are more live episodes from our tour on Wondry Plus that you can listen to. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early and add free on Wondry Plus that you can listen to. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early
嘿，听众朋友们，欢迎收听《聪明糊涂账》（SmartLess）。在进入这期精彩的节目之前，我只想占用大家一点时间来稍微做个铺垫。去年，肖恩、杰森和我进行了一次“聪明糊涂账”巡演，我们从布鲁克林到洛杉矶，在成千上万的忠实粉丝面前现场录制了10期节目。你猜怎么着？现在，Wondry Plus上还有更多我们在巡演中的现场节目供你收听。你可以在Wondry Plus上提前四周且无广告地收听这些节目。你可以提前四周收听这些节目
and add free on Wondry Plus, after which you can hear them for free wherever you get your podcast. Find Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. All right. Welcome to SmartLess. This is officially a cold open, I guess. This is a cold open.
并且在Wondry Plus上无广告收听，之后你可以在任何你获取播客的地方免费收听它们。在Wondry app或苹果播客上找到Wondry Plus。好了。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。我想，这正式算是一个无准备开场白了。这是一个无准备开场白。
Right? This is like a... Like on the podcast, we just kind of talk. Before we say what the name of the day. Like an intro, and then we got to be like... Yeah. We got to be like... Professional.
对吧？这就像一个……就像在播客里，我们就是随便聊聊。在我们说出今天的主题之前。就像一个引子，然后我们得像……对。我们得像……很专业。
And like, oh, we... We get to... We usually... You're just copying what I'm saying. You're just copying what I'm saying. You're just copying what I'm saying. I don't know how to tap into this. That's okay.
而且，哦，我们……我们得……我们通常……你只是在学我说话。你只是在学我说话。你只是在学我说话。我不知道该怎么切入这个状态。没关系。
Just say the only thing that you know what to say. Welcome to Smartless! Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. We're so happy to be in Boston. Nice to be here. Oh my God. Tonight. And you guys, you guys rolled out your nicest weather for us.
那就说你唯一知道该怎么说的那句话。欢迎来到《SmartLess》！Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。我们很高兴来到波斯顿。很高兴来到这里。哦天哪。今晚。而且你们，你们把最好的天气留给了我们。
Yeah. Oh, felt like being home in Canada almost. But thank you, thank you, thank you. Not only for listening to our garbage, but coming out and looking out at us. Yeah. And you guys, you guys rolled out your nicest weather for us. Yeah. Oh, felt like being home in Canada almost. Uh, but thank you, thank you, thank you, not only for listening to our garbage,
是啊。哦，感觉几乎就像回到了加拿大的家一样。但是谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你们。不仅谢谢你们听我们的废话，还肯出来看我们。对。而且你们，你们把最好的天气留给了我们。是啊。哦，感觉几乎就像回到了加拿大的家一样。呃，但是谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你们，不仅谢谢你们听我们的废话，
but coming out and looking at our garbage. Yeah. It's a better way to say that. No, the way, but better way to say that. Um, so, all right, let's sit down. Yeah, we're just excited. Sit down. Um, so, uh, oh wait, somebody left their phone here.
还出来看我们的废话。对。这么说会更好一点。不，这么说，但有更好的说法。嗯，所以，好吧，我们坐下吧。对，我们太兴奋了。坐下。嗯，所以，呃，哦等等，有人把手机落这儿了。
That's me. I brought it into my pocket. I don't know why. If I do get a call though, we're just gonna take a quick break, okay? From the inspection. It is mine. Sorry. The camera was on too, Granddad. Yeah, my flash was on. Yeah, put it over here. And I'm showing gum.
那是我的。我把它塞进口袋里了，我不知道为什么。不过如果真有电话打进来，我们就暂停一下，好吗？从检查开始。是我的。对不起。镜头还开着呢，老头子。对，我的闪光灯开着。对，把它放这儿。我还嚼着口香糖呢。
So really professional operation here. All right, so let me ask you something. Yeah. Do you guys, how is traveling going for you with all of this? Great interview question. What about signs? I did a little preparation, is that? No, I wonder what I want to know that because,
所以这里真的是个非常专业的运作。好吧，那让我问你们个问题。对。你们大家，你们对这趟旅行感觉怎么样？多棒的采访问题啊。那标志呢？我做了一点准备，是吗？不，我想知道这个是因为，
as of this morning, Will started calling me Katy Perry because I bring so many outfits with me. I don't know. This is the best you could use. It was just, I know. Well, the true story is the sweet girl who picks out my clothes for me because I don't know how to do that, clearly. She sent me, she sent over, Godlover,
就在今天早上，威尔开始叫我凯蒂·佩里（Katy Perry），因为我带的衣服实在太多了。我不知道。这是你能想到的最好的借口了。这只是，我知道。好吧，真实的故事是，那个挑衣裳的甜美女孩——因为我显然不会干这个——她帮我把衣服选好，天哪，
she's a really close family, but she sent me over two of the exact same outfits today. So I kind of put this together, Willie Nilly. It is a new thing for us because we, you know, we do this thing on our laptops. And we were. And we know we're together, we're together, we're together. We wear pajamas. Yeah.
她真的是个很好的人，但她今天竟然给我寄了两套一模一样的衣服。所以我只好东拼凑西凑地搞了这么一身。这对我们来说是个新鲜事，因为我们呢，我们平时都是用笔记本电脑干这事的。而且我们……。我们知道我们在哪，我们在一起，我们在一起。我们穿着睡衣。对。
So this whole notion of having to dress and actually have a specific time and all that stuff, it is odd. Yeah, I think. And that there's people here. Yeah, yeah. And usually one of us is a few minutes late. I am commonly late.
所以这种必须穿衣服、还得有具体时间安排之类的事情，真的很奇怪。对，我觉得。而且这里还有人在。对，对，对。而且我们通常总有一个人会迟到几分钟。我通常都迟到。
Oh, that's you. I am. OK. But here's it. I don't like to be, if you're early, you've wasted time, right? You have an issue. I know.
哦，那说的是你。我是。好吧。但重点是。我不喜欢，如果你到早了，你就浪费了时间，对吧？你脑子有问题。我知道。
I've just got a lot of milling around. Go out there. Just wait. I'm interested. I go to a doctor's office now late, so I don't have to wait the 20 minutes they make me wait. Right. I just go.
我只是有很多闲逛的时间。去外面。就等着吧。我很有兴趣。我现在去诊所都会故意迟到，这样我就不用等他们让我等的20分钟了。对。我直接去。
By the way, you still have to wait. But do they like that? They love me for that. This sounds familiar. I feel like we talked about this, maybe. I don't think we have a time. I don't think we've ever. I don't think we've ever.
顺便说一句，你还是得等。但他们喜欢这样吗？他们可太爱我这样了。这听起来很耳熟。我觉得我们可能聊过这个，也许吧。我觉得我们没定过时间。我觉得我们从来没……。我觉得我们从来没……。
You're never early or late, are you? No, I'm right on time. You're always right on time. What is that? I'll never ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever I'm going, I don't know, ask Kenny Perry over here. Like that, so we'll just bully. And then we all have, you're gonna make me roar in our head. And Jason, you've been singing that all day. I can't, I'm so, I can't, is everybody, when you get a song you can't get it out, am I the only one like, but like, it lasts an abnormal amount of time, like,
你从来没有早到过或迟到过，对吧？不，我总是准时。你总是那么准时。这是怎么回事？我绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对绝对.我要走了，我不知道，去问问那边的凯蒂·佩里。就像那样，所以我们只会霸凌。然后我们都有，你让我在脑子里咆哮了。还有杰森，你一整天都在唱那个。我不能，我太，我不能，是不是所有人，当你脑子里有首歌挥之不去的时候，我是唯一一个像这样的人吗，但是它会持续异常长的时间，比如，
a week, I'll get something stuck on my head. They say, like, to count down backwards from a certain amount of number and that will make you stop thinking of time, like, a week. I'll get something stuck on my head. They say, like, to count down backwards from a certain amount of number and that will make you stop thinking of the, are you doing it right now? It just worked for songs. Yeah. Because there's a lot of shit I'd like to forget.
一个星期，我脑子里都会一直想着一首歌。他们说，比如从某个特定的数字开始倒数，那就会让你不再去想时间，比如，一个星期。我脑子里都会一直想着一首歌。他们说，比如从某个特定的数字开始倒数，那就会让你不再去想那个，你现在在倒数吗？它对歌曲很管用。对。因为有很多破事我都想忘掉。
Like that kind of thing. Yeah, so if that works, I want to do that. Well, the other thing that happens to me yesterday was I found, my back has been itching, and then we have, we have, are you gonna get it? Yeah, so we have this. He's backing into a plug for hypoconyl.
比如那种事情。对，所以如果这管用，我想试试。好吧，昨天发生在我身上的另一件事是，我发现，我的背一直在发痒，然后我们有，我们有，你打算说吗？对，所以我们有这个。他靠在了一个插座上，为了针灸。
No, I know, I was other podcast. Then it is. And, and, and. So Sean, wearing conversations in the hotel room, and Sean does a lot of this, he's like, uh-huh, what's going on, and he gets up against the door and he's going, really?
不，我知道，我是在另一个播客里。然后确实是。而且，而且，而且。所以肖恩，我们在酒店房间里聊天，肖恩经常这样，他说，嗯哼，怎么回事，然后他靠在门上说，真的吗？
Yeah. Like a dog, like a non-stop. Like a dog, and scratches his, yeah. So then we, our friend Eli's with us, and who we love, and it's a very good friend of ours. And I'm like, what's going on with my back? He goes, take a short off, let me see. So I took the thing and I'm back and he goes,
对。像一只狗，一直不停地。像一只狗，抓着他的，对。然后我们，我们的朋友伊莱和我们在一起，我们很喜欢他，他是我们的好朋友。然后我说，我的背怎么了？他说，把衬衫脱了，让我看看。所以我把那个东西脱了，转过身去，他说，
that's shingles. Truly. Yeah, he said I have shingles. Oh, you know there? No. No, he went. Oh my God, that shingles. And I'm like, what? I just got the vaccine for shingles.
那是带状疱疹。真的。对，他说我得了带状疱疹。哦，你知道那里吗？不。不，他去了。哦天哪，那是带状疱疹。然后我说，什么？我刚打过带状疱疹疫苗啊。
How could I have shingles. And I'm like, what? I just got the vaccine for shingles. How could I have shingles? Right. Because if there's a vaccine for it, it's in my body. Yeah. Yeah. Oh. Yeah. Right.
我怎么会得带状疱疹。然后我说，什么？我刚打过带状疱疹疫苗啊。我怎么会得带状疱疹？对啊。因为如果有疫苗的话，它就在我体内啊。对。对。哦。对。对。
Yeah. Good health isn't political. No. Say that again. Thank you. No, thank you. You can get a show. You just got a pen. No. Say that again. Thank you. No, thank you. You can get a show.
对。健康可不是政治问题。不。再说一遍。谢谢。不，谢谢。你可以去看个演出。你刚拿到一支笔。不。再说一遍。谢谢。不，谢谢。你可以去看个演出。
He's got a pen. Yeah. I used to pen earlier to write my intro. And since we're talking about science, it's a great segue. Fellas. I wanted to tap into the brain power of this city. OK.
他有一支笔。对。我刚才用这支笔写我的开场白了。既然我们在谈论科学，这是一个很好的过渡。伙计们。我想借用一下这座城市的脑力。好吧。
We got a big brain coming out. This fella has a master's and a PhD from Berkeley. He's a fellow at Princeton. He has tenure at Penn. He arrived here at MIT in 2004 where he still works today. He does it all from physics to cosmology to quantum stuff and computers. He's going to explain what it is.
我们迎来了超级大脑。这家伙拥有伯克利大学的硕士和博士学位。他是普林斯顿大学的研究员。他在宾夕法尼亚大学拥有终身教职。他于2004年抵达麻省理工学院，至今仍在这里工作。他无所不能，从物理学到宇宙学，再到量子技术和计算机。他会亲自解释这些是什么。
Stephen Hawking. Will Ferrell. Stephen Hawking. Please welcome a guy you can definitely make us all more smart, not less smart. Smart less, you get it? Max Tagmark. Oh!
斯蒂芬·霍金。威尔·法瑞尔。斯蒂芬·霍金。请欢迎一位绝对能让我们所有人都变得更聪明、而不是更笨的家伙。“SmartLess”，懂了吗？马克斯·泰格马克（Max Tegmark）。哦！
What? Max Tagmark. Come on, Max. Oh my gosh. Get out of here. There he is. Max. This is Max, Mark. Hello, man.
什么？马克斯·泰格马克。来吧，马克斯。哦天哪。快请进。他来了。马克斯。这是马克斯·马克。你好，老兄。
It's so nice to meet you. Come on, please. This is so exciting. Well, see, we have the same stylist. Oh, wow. He wears a little better than you do. He certainly does. Now, can you do a better job than I just did explaining?
很高兴见到你。快请进，请。这太令人兴奋了。你看，我们穿的是同一个造型师的衣服。哦，哇。他穿起来比你好看一点。他确实如此。那么，你能比我刚才做得更好，来解释一下吗？
What it is that you do, what it, first of all, how do you introduce yourself, call yourself what you do a better job than I just did explaining what it is that you do? What it is? First of all, how do you introduce yourself? I call yourself what you do. By the way, you look like a rock star. Well, it depends on what I want. Like if I were on a long flight, and I just want to be left alone, and the person asking you what you do, your pedophile. Physics. That was my worst subject in my school. Five hours of silence. Right. Right, right. But you are a wanna talk, yeah.
你到底是做什么的，你，首先，你怎么向别人介绍自己，称呼你自己——能比我刚才更好地解释你是做什么的吗？到底是做什么的？首先，你怎么向别人介绍自己？你如何称呼自己的工作？顺便说一句，你看上去像个摇滚明星。这取决于我想要什么。比如如果我在坐长途飞机，我只是想安安静静不被打扰，当别人问你是干什么的时候，你是个恋童癖。物理学。那是我在学校里最差的科目。五小时的绝对安静。对。对，对。但如果你想聊天，是的。
I'm the old astronomy. I'm like, oh, I'm a Virgo. Oh, right. Well, maybe I could say cosmology, they'll be talking about eyeliner, makeup. Okay, so the class you teach is, oh, it's whenever they want me to torture the students with that year.
我是天文学元老。我会说，哦，我是处女座。哦，对。好吧，也许我可以说是宇宙学，他们就会开始谈论眼线笔和化妆品了。好吧，所以你教的课程是，哦，就是每当我想要用它来折磨学生的那个学期。
So it can be either torturing the freshman, it came out of high school with the basic physics of how stuff moves to doing the torturing, the grad students with some advanced topics about our universe. Okay. Or I taught, most of my time I spend actually torturing my grad students, doing research on artificial intelligence. Okay, okay I toured most of my time I spend actually torching, torching my grad students, doing research on artificial intelligence. Okay, okay good. By the way, this is everything I'm for. Yeah, well you marry me, no kidding.
所以它可以是折磨大一新生，他们刚从高中毕业，学的是事物如何运动的基础物理学，也可以是折磨研究生，教他们一些关于我们宇宙的高级课题。好吧。或者我教，我其实把大部分时间都花在折磨我的研究生身上，研究人工智能。好吧，好吧，我把大部分时间都花在折磨，折磨我的研究生身上，研究人工智能。好吧，好吧，很好。顺便说一句，这正合我意。对，那你嫁给我吧，不开玩笑。
I want to go, you probably have a question. That's what I want to go over there. Well, I saw this documentary on artificial intelligence and what I was surprised to learn is that it's not about robots, like the Steven Spielberg movie. It's more about the amount of computing speed that we now can do such that, like, I think they said in the documentary, you can put all the books that have ever been written
我想去，你可能有个问题。这就是我想去那边说。好吧，我看了关于人工智能的纪录片，让我惊讶的是，它不是像斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格电影里那种机器人。它更多的是关于我们现在能够达到的计算速度，比如，我想他们在纪录片里说过，你可以把写过的所有书
into a computer now, and you're gonna tell me whether I'm right or wrong, I bet I'm close to right, but probably wrong. You can put all the books into a computer now, and you're going to tell me whether I'm right or wrong. I bet I'm close to right, but probably wrong. You can put all the books into a computer, and the computer will ingest all that information, separate it out, and be able to give you an answer about anything that you can ask them if the information was in any of those books from languages to rocks to... Isn't that called Google, though? of those books from languages to rocks to the, I mean, isn't that called Google though? Well, I'm sure you could explain that,
现在都输入一台电脑里，你来告诉我我说得对不对，我敢打赌我猜得差不多，但也可能大错特错。你现在可以把所有的书都输入电脑，然后你来告诉我我说得对不对。我敢打赌我猜得差不多，但也可能大错特错。你可以把所有的书都输入电脑，电脑就会吞噬所有这些信息，把它们分类，并且无论你问它什么问题，它都能给你一个答案，只要这些信息存在于其中的任何一本书里，从语言到岩石再到……这不就是所谓的谷歌吗？从语言到岩石再到，我的意思是，这不就是所谓的谷歌吗？好吧，我确信你可以解释这一点，
but it's like that's artificial intelligence. That's, well, yes and no. So on one hand, yeah, you can take all the books that were printed and put them on a memory card. It's so small that you might have a hard time finding it in your pocket, but that doesn't mean that a computer necessarily understands what's there, just because it can store it and kind of regurgitate it back to you, right? And I think the truth is, despite a lot of hype, that artificial intelligence is still
但这就好比，这就是人工智能。那是，怎么说呢，既是也不是。一方面，是的，你可以把所有印刷出来的书籍都拿来，把它们存放在一张存储卡上。它小得你可能很难在口袋里找到它，但这并不意味着电脑就一定能理解里面的内容，仅仅因为它能存储并把它们背诵给你，对吧？我认为事实是，尽管有很多炒作，但与人类甚至猫狗相比，人工智能今天
mostly pretty dumb today compared to humans or even cats and dogs. But, you know, that doesn't mean it's gonna remain that way. I think a lot of people make the huge mistake of thinking just because AI is kind of dumb today, it's always gonna be that way. Right. Well, shouldn't we keep it dumb because if we let it get too smart, et cetera? What is that threshold of the point of no return? Yeah, because remember that thing about Facebook where they started, I don't know if this is true, they started doing like AI technology,
大体上还是相当愚蠢的。但是，你知道，这并不意味着它会一直保持这样。我认为很多人犯了一个巨大的错误，仅仅因为人工智能今天有点笨，就认为它永远都会这样。对。那我们难道不应该让它保持愚蠢吗？因为如果我们让它变得太聪明，等等？那个不归点的临界阈值是什么？对，因为还记得关于脸书（Facebook）的那件事吗，他们开始——我不知道这是不是真的——他们开始使用人工智能技术，
they just started talking to each other and they shut it down, is that true? They were gossiping. Yeah. It's true, but I think Hollywood and media often make us worry about the wrong things. They, they, they, the, what do you mean? Yeah. First of all, people often ask me, things. What do you mean?
它们只是开始互相交谈，然后他们就把系统关了，这是真的吗？它们在说八卦。是真的，但我觉得好莱坞和媒体经常让我们为错误的事情担忧。他们，他们，他们，那个，你是什么意思？对。首先，人们经常问我，事情。你是什么意思？
First of all, people often ask me if I should fear AI or be excited about it. The answer is obviously both. AI is like any technology. It's not evil or good. If I ask you, what about fire? How do you feel? I'm forward or against it. What are you going to say?
首先，人们经常问我，我是应该害怕人工智能还是对它感到兴奋。答案显然是两者皆有。人工智能就像任何技术一样。它既不是邪恶的，也不是善良的。如果我问你，火呢？你有什么感觉？我是支持还是反对它。你会怎么说？
Right. It can hurt if you use it incorrectly. Exactly. And the same thing with all of the technology, the only difference is that AI is going to be the most powerful technology ever. Because look, why is it that we humans here are the most powerful species on this planet?
对。如果你用得不对，它就会伤到你。没错。所有的技术都是如此，唯一的区别在于，人工智能将成为有史以来最强大的技术。因为你看，为什么我们人类是这个星球上最强大的物种？
Fuckin' A. Is it because we have bigger biceps, sharper teeth? Then the tigers know it's because we're smarter, right? So obviously, if we make machines that are way smarter than us, which is obviously possible and most researchers in the field think it's going to happen in our lifetime, then it's either going to clearly either going to be the best thing ever or the worst thing ever. Yeah, so my question is, when it's the worst thing ever, by the time it becomes the worst thing ever, then we're fucked.
真他妈的。是因为我们有更大的二头肌、更尖锐的牙齿吗？比起老虎，才不是呢，是因为我们更聪明，对吧？所以很显然，如果我们制造出远比我们聪明的机器——这显然是可能的，而且该领域的绝大多数研究人员都认为这会在我们有生之年发生——那么它显然要么会成为有史以来最好的事情，要么会成为有史以来最糟糕的事情。对，所以我的问题是，当它变成最糟糕的事情时，等它变成最糟糕的事情的时候，我们就完蛋了。
Then it's too late, yeah, you want to kind of... So let it be the worst thing ever. So that's the catch, though. We humans have had to play this game over and over again with where technology got more powerful. I mean, we're trying to win this race, making sure the wisdom with which you manage the tech keeps pace with the power manage the tech keeps pace with
那就太迟了，对吧，你得……所以让它成为最糟糕的事情吧。这就是难点所在。我们人类不得不一次又一次地玩这个游戏，随着技术的日益强大。我的意思是，我们正在努力赢得这场竞赛，确保你用来管理技术的智慧能够跟上技术发展的步伐。管理技术的步伐跟得上
the power of the tech. And we always use the same strategy, learn from mistakes. But it seems like the big safeguard that we have as humans, that we don't yet have with machines, is that we have ethics, we have empathy, we have emotion. And what is the computer program that you would need to put together to inject that into this new machine with all of this information. We put some snuggles in it. Yeah.
技术的威力。而我们总是使用相同的策略，从错误中吸取教训。但似乎作为人类，我们拥有的最大保障——而机器目前还不具备——是我们拥有道德、同情心、情感。你需要把什么样的计算机程序组合在一起，才能将这些东西注入这台拥有所有这些信息的全新机器中。我们在里面放一些拥抱玩偶。对。
That's a fantastic question. What's the snuggles recipe? So you're hitting exactly my wish list. If you want to have ever more powerful AI that's actually beneficial for humanity, right? So you can be excited, right? I'm horrified about the future. There are three things you're going to need. First, you're going to want to need the AI
这是一个非常棒的问题。拥抱玩偶的配方是什么？所以你正中我的愿望清单。如果你想拥有越来越强大、对人类真正有益的人工智能，对吧？所以你可以兴奋，对吧？我对未来感到惊恐。你需要三样东西。首先，你需要人工智能
to understand our human goals. And then get it to actually adopt the goals, and then to actually keep those goals as it gets smarter. And if you think about it for a little longer, each of these are really hard. So suppose you have a tell your future self-driving card and take you to Logan Airport as fast as possible. And then you get their covered in vomit
理解人类的目标。然后让它真正采纳这些目标，接着在它变得越来越聪明的过程中始终保持这些目标。如果你再多想一会儿，这每一项都非常难。假设你告诉未来的自动驾驶汽车，带我去洛根机场，越快越好。然后你到达那里时浑身是呕吐物，
and chased by helicopters and you're like That's not what I meant. Yeah, and the car goes like that's exactly what you ask for you know, it's clearly like they do talk like that literally Literally are you he's the Terminator? He sounds like the Terminator and he's talking about Terminator stuff So we humans have so much more background knowledge that a machine doesn't take over, because it's like very alien species of a source.
还被直升机追赶，然后你会说：这不是我的意思！对，然后汽车会说：这正是你要求的，你知道，很明显，它们说话确实是那样。简直是，你是认真的吗？他是终结者？他听起来就像终结者，而且他在谈论终结者的事。所以我们人类拥有如此多的背景知识，而机器却没有，因为它们就像外星物种一样。
So that's hard for starters. And then, suppose you can get that right. Now, let me stop you there. Is there any chance of getting that right? In other words, the formula, the equation that equals emotion, responsibility, ethics, can you even create a computer equation for that? I think right now we don't know how to do it.
所以首先这很难。然后，假设你能把这一点做好。现在，我得打断你一下。有任何可能把这一点做好吗？换句话说，代表情感、责任感、道德的公式或方程式，你甚至能为之创造一个计算机方程式吗？我想现在我们还不知道怎么做。
It's probably possible. We were not working enough on it. Yeah, the catch is, for computers, or just like, if you think of a baby, six months old, you're not going to explain the fine details of ethics to them, because they can't quite get it yet. By the time they're a teenager, they're not going to sit to you anymore. Those of you who have kids out there, right? So, but you have a window with human children while when they're smart enough to get it and may still malleable enough
这可能是可能的。我们在这方面的工作做得还不够。对，问题在于，对计算机来说，或者就像，如果你把一个六个月大的婴儿放在那儿，你不会向他们解释道德的微小细节，因为他们还无法完全理解。等他们到了十几岁，他们就不再听你的了。在座各位有孩子的都知道，对吧？所以，你与人类儿童相处有一个窗口期，当他们足够聪明能够理解，而且可能还足够具有可塑性，
to hopefully pay attention, right? With computers though, they might blow through that so quickly that window. Did you see X Machina? Did anybody see X Machina? with computers though, they might blow through that so quickly. That window. Did you see X Machina? Did anybody see X Machina? Yeah, that's amazing. That's amazing. What did you see? Yeah, let's put that for X Machina.
希望还能听进去，对吧？然而对于计算机来说，它们穿过那个窗口的速度可能会非常快。你看过《机械姬》（Ex Machina）吗？有人看过《机械姬》吗？然而对于计算机来说，它们穿过那个窗口的速度可能会非常快。那个窗口。你看过《机械姬》吗？有人看过《机械姬》吗？对，太棒了。太棒了。你看过吗？对，让我们为《机械姬》鼓掌。
No, what is the most accurate film to science? Like, is it how in 2001 or X Machina? Those are my top two actually, because how emphasizes this key thing that the thing you should really fear in an advanced AI is not that it's going to turn evil, but that it's going to just turn really competent and not have its goals aligned with yours. That's what happens in how, like, no spoilers. Right. And like that, taxi, I mean.
不，哪部电影最符合科学？比如，是《2001太空漫游》里的HAL，还是《机械姬》？这其实是我的前两名，因为HAL强调了关键一点：你应该真正害怕先进人工智能的原因，不是它会变得邪恶，而是它会变得非常能干，但它的目标却与你的不一致。这就是《HAL》里发生的事，剧透就到这里。对。就像那个，出租车，我是说。
60 years in were good, but. But then the other thing you should also worry about is even if you can solve all these things And I think it might take 30 years to figure this out, which is where we should start now Not you know the night before some folks on too much red bull switching on right? I mean I got two cans in me right now Not in the can not in my can but in super tellers away from Okay, but the other thing is even if you manage to solve those technical problems, which we should have more research on, you also have to worry about human society.
前60年我们过得很好，但是。但另一件你也应该担心的事情是，即使你能解决所有这些问题——我想这可能需要30年才能弄清楚，而这正是我们现在应该开始的时候，而不是在某些人喝了太多红牛准备通宵开工的前一天晚上才开始。我的意思是，我现在肚子里有两罐红牛。不是罐子里，不是在我手里的罐子里，而是在超级……不管怎样。好吧，但另一件是，即使你设法解决了这些技术问题——我们确实应该对此进行更多研究，你还得担心人类社会。
Because just think for a moment about your least favorite leader on the planet. Don't tell me who it is. So we don't offend anyone in the audience. Thank you for thinking about it. You're just a leader. Imagine their face for a moment here. And they imagine they are the one who controls the first superintelligence and take control
因为只要想一想地球上你最讨厌的领导人。别告诉我他是谁。这样我们就不会冒犯观众中的任何人了。谢谢你们去想。你只需要想想。想象一下他们此刻的面孔。然后想象他们是控制第一个超级智能、并控制整个星球、强加他们意志的那个人。你对此有什么感觉？
over the whole planet and impose their will. How does that make you feel? Yeah, not good. None of it makes me feel great. Listen, after a lifetime of doing all this stuff with the right, how does it feel to talk to an actual robot? Like that must feel... Yeah.
对，感觉不好。没有哪一点让我觉得很好。听着，在一生中经历过所有这些与正确有关的事情之后，跟一个真正的机器人交谈是什么感觉？那感觉一定……对。
And we will be right back. Thanks to True Classic for supporting the show. This is my favorite time of year, because you've got your beach parties and your barbecue is in hanging at the beach and you name it, getting on your bike and with the kids and outside and everything. And while I love the warmer weather, it can be hard to dress for the heat, especially for us guys who just want a comfortable t-shirt that fits great.
我们马上回来。感谢True Classic对本节目的支持。这是我一年中最喜欢的季节，因为有海滩派对、烧烤、在海滩闲逛等等，骑着自行车和孩子们在户外玩耍，诸如此类。虽然我喜欢更温暖的天气，但要适应炎热的天气可能很难，特别是对我们这些只想穿一件合身又舒适的T恤的男士来说。
And that is why I love true classic, because they make it easy to look and feel great all summer long with their perfect fitting shirts, shorts, pants, all at prices that your wallet will love. I feel like I'm 53. I know, hold your amazement, but I feel like I've spent my I know it. Hold your amazement. But I feel like I've spent my entire life looking for a t-shirt that fits right. You just want all that, you want it to fit right through the shoulders, right through here, right through there, that it's not too snug, but it's not too, but all those things.
这就是我喜欢True Classic的原因，因为他们用完美合身的衬衫、短裤、裤子，让你整个夏天都能轻松保持帅气和好状态，而且价格也是你的钱包会喜欢的。我觉得我53岁了。我知道，收起你们的惊讶，但我感觉我已经把我的——我知道。收起你们的惊讶。但我觉得我一生都在寻找一件合身的T恤。你只是想要所有这些，你希望它在肩膀处合身，在这里合身，在那里合身，它不会太紧，也不会太松，所有这些要求。
And it has taken me this long to find it, and it's thanks to True Classic. So let's talk about these True Classic teas for a second. And honestly, I'm not kidding when I say, I've been blown away by how perfectly this fits me. It's like my new secret weapon almost. And it just makes me look super fit with the way that it hugs my arms and my chest. If I do say so myself.
我花了这么长时间才找到它，这都要归功于True Classic。所以我们来聊聊这些True Classic的T恤。老实说，当我这么说时我绝不是在开玩笑，这件衣服的剪裁如此完美，真的让我惊艳到了。它几乎成了我的新秘密武器。它紧紧贴合我的手臂和胸部，让我看起来超级健美。如果我自己这么说的话。
And just the right amount of room through the body. So, and even better, they've got this new summer ready colors and the coming packs so you can have a shirt for every day of the week. So, if you're ready to upgrade your look and your wardrobe, shop now at TrueClassic.com and save 25% off with the code SmartLess. Look your best, feel your best, and be your best with True Classic. SmartLess is supported by NetSuite by Oracle. If your business earns millions or tens of millions of revenues, stop what you're doing and take a listen because NetSuite by Oracle has
而且身体周围也有恰到好处的空间。更棒的是，他们推出了适合夏天的全新颜色和超值套装，这样你一周七天每天都能穿一件衬衫。所以，如果你准备好升级你的造型和衣橱，现在就去TrueClassic.com购买，使用优惠代码SmartLess即可享受25%的折扣。穿出最佳状态，感觉最佳状态，用True Classic做最好的自己。SmartLess由Oracle旗下的NetSuite赞助支持。如果你的企业创造了数百万或数千万的收入，请停下你正在做的事情并听一听，因为Oracle旗下的NetSuite
just rolled out the best offer we've ever seen. NetSuite gives you the visibility and control you need to make better decisions faster. And for the first time in NetSuite's 25 years as the number one cloud financial system, you can defer payments of a full NetSuite implementation for six months. That's no payment and no interest for six months
刚刚推出了我们见过的最优惠的方案。NetSuite为你提供更好的更快决策所需的可见性和控制力。在NetSuite作为头号云财务系统的25年历史中，这是第一次，你可以将整套NetSuite系统的实施费用延迟六个月支付。也就是六个月内零首付、零利息，
and you can take advantage of this special financing offer today. NetSuite is number one because they give your business everything you need in real time all in one place. To reduce manual process, boost efficiency, build forecasts and increase productivity across every department. Look, having all of your information in one place is kind of the name of the game, and that's what NetSuite has. More than 36,000 companies have already upgraded to NetSuite, gaining visibility and control over the financials, inventory, HR, e-commerce, and more. If you've been sizing NetSuite up to make the switch, then you know this deal is unprecedented.
你今天就可以利用这个特殊的融资优惠。NetSuite之所以排名第一，是因为他们将你的业务所需的一切实时集中在一个地方。从而减少人工流程、提升效率、构建预测并提高各部门的生产力。看，把所有的信息都集中在一个地方可以说是成功的关键，而这正是NetSuite所具备的。超过36,000家公司已经升级到了NetSuite，获得了对其财务、库存、人力资源、电子商务等的可见性和控制力。如果你一直在评估NetSuite以进行系统切换，那么你就会知道这笔交易是史无前例的。
No interest, no payments. Take advantage of the special financing offer at netsuite.com slash smartless. Netsuite.com slash smartless to get the visibility and control you need to weather any storm. Netsuite.com slash smartless. He's a Swav billionaire owner of the Delus Mavericks and the sharkiest shark on Shark Tank Yes, I'm talking about Mr. Business himself Mark Cuban and our smartless interview with him is available now four weeks early on Wondery Plus. Mark unravels the secrets behind the phenomenal success and recounts the magical moment when
零利息，零付款。请访问netsuite.com/smartless利用这一特殊融资优惠。Netsuite.com/smartless，获取应对任何风暴所需的可见性和控制力。Netsuite.com/smartless。他是达拉斯小牛队（Dallas Mavericks）温文尔雅的亿万富翁老板，也是《创智赢家》（Shark Tank）里最具鲨鱼特质的鲨鱼。没错，我说的就是商业先生本人马克·库班（Mark Cuban），我们对他的《SmartLess》采访现在已经可以在Wondry Plus上提前四周收听了。马克揭开了巨大成功背后的秘密，并回忆了那个神奇的时刻，
he became a member of the billionaire club. Our interview with Mark Cuban was recorded live in Chicago in front of thousands of our biggest fans from our SmartList tour. This is the seventh of 10 interviews with new episodes releasing every Thursday. We're talking with celebrities and icons like the Great Will Ferrell, Conan O'Brien, Kevin Hart, Jimmy Kimmel, and so many more. And it wouldn't be SmartList if Scotty and I didn't take the opportunity to pitch Mark Cuban our new idea.
当时他成为了亿万富翁俱乐部的一员。我们对马克·库班的采访是在芝加哥现场录制的，台下坐着我们“SmartLess”巡演中成千上万最热情的粉丝。这是10场采访中的第7场，每周四都会发布新节目。我们将与伟大的威尔·法瑞尔、柯南·奥布莱恩、凯文·哈特、吉米·金梅尔等名人和偶像进行对话。如果我和斯科蒂没有抓住机会向马克·库班推销我们的小创意，那就不配叫《SmartLess》了。
Will we land a deal of a lifetime? You'll have to listen to find out. We call that a tease in the biz. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early and add free with Wondery Plus, find Wondery Plus in the Wondery app or on Apple Podcasts. And now back to the show. How so is there is do do people have proprietary right over certain stuff or does one country control a lot like who's leading China's leading the AI is are they not us in China are both very strong I mean most research suggests that it's us is still kind of ahead but there there's a lot of hype around both countries of course try to try to research how in USA I'm gonna lose it and I'll bet one
我们能谈成一笔千载难逢的交易吗？你得听了才知道。我们在行内把这叫做“悬念钩子”。你可以在Wondry Plus上提前四周且无广告地收听这些节目，在Wondry app或苹果播客上找到Wondry Plus。现在让我们回到节目中。那么，人们对某些东西是否有专有权，或者是否有一个国家控制了大部分——谁在领先？中国的AI在领先吗？难道不是吗？我们和中国都很强。我的意思是，大多数研究表明，我们美国似乎仍然处于领先地位，但两个国家周围都有很多炒作，当然，他们试图去研究中国和美国的人工智能……我快疯了，我敢打赌总有一天，
day and I'll bet and I'll bet when they say the USA, they're talking about MIT and they're probably talking about him. Well, you know how it goes. Both countries are trying to proclaim that the both countries researchers are trying to claim that the other one is the heads of it, because you get more funding. That's how we researchers always do it. But seriously, the interesting key here,
我敢打赌，当他们说美国时，他们指的是麻省理工学院，可能还指的是他。好吧，你知道这是怎么回事。两个国家都在试图宣称——两国的研究人员都在试图声称对方才是领先者，因为这样能获得更多资金。我们研究人员向来都是这么干的。但说真的，这里有趣的关键点，
I think, is ultimately, it's not really, you know, matter which country gets it for. It's going to matter most, is it going to be us who control the machines, or are they who control us? I mean, but it really is. It's all joking, so I'm obsessed with the Terminator movies and anything. So I find that. Sure, all joking aside. Yeah, joking aside.
我认为，最终其实并不是——你知道，哪个国家率先掌握并不重要。最重要的是，究竟是我们控制机器，还是机器控制我们？我的意思是，真的就是这样。开玩笑归开玩笑，我其实对《终结者》电影和所有相关的东西着迷。所以我觉得……当然，抛开玩笑不谈。对，抛开玩笑不谈。
Yeah. Yeah, let's put the jokes aside and in no talk about it. No, but that's kind of the idea behind a lot of Hollywood movies and stuff. Is that what if the A.I. has become more intelligent than the human? But here's the thing, I saw something on 60 minutes years ago, which fascinates me to this day, and I'm not going to get this right, but it's some guy. And he rune's eyebrows. That's it.
对。对，我们把玩笑放在一边，不再谈论这个。不，但这正是好莱坞许多电影背后的理念。如果人工智能变得比人类更聪明会怎么样？但问题是，多年前我在《60分钟》（60 Minutes）节目里看到过一期内容，至今让我着迷，我可能记不太准，但那是某个家伙。还有他那毛茸茸的眉毛。就是这样。
No, so... It's never wonder why. Never wonder why. I opened my old desk drawer and I got a tie from the 1968 Democratic Convention. It's got soup on it. I don't like soup. No one knows who Andy Rooney is.
不，所以……永远不要好奇为什么。永远不要好奇为什么。我打开我旧的办公桌抽屉，找到了一根1968年民主党全国代表大会的领带。上面沾了汤。我不喜欢喝汤。没有人知道安迪·鲁尼（Andy Rooney）是谁。
Yeah, yeah. It's also his DAC-shepard impression. But anyway. It was true. But anyway, so there is this guy. The interviewer was interviewing the scientists who claimed to have come up with this idea. This thing was wrapped around his ear, and it was tied
对，对。这也是他对戴克·夏帕德（Dax Shepard）的模仿。不过话说回来。是真的。但不管怎样，有这么个家伙。采访者正在采访那个声称想出这个点子的科学家。那个东西缠在他的耳朵上，
to his side of his head. And the interviewer was asking him a question, like, what's the population of Utah? And all he had to do was think of the answer and it popped up on the screen. Do you know what I'm talking about? Yeah, well, this sort of stuff you have to do is think of the answer and it popped up on the screen. Do you know what I'm talking about? This kind of stuff you can already do with your grandma if you have a connection to Google.
固定在他脑袋的一侧。采访者问他一个问题，比如，犹他州的人口是多少？他所要做的就是想出答案，然后答案就弹出了屏幕上。你知道我在说什么吗？对，这种事情你只要想一下答案，它就会弹在屏幕上。你知道我在说什么吗？这种事情如果你连接了谷歌，用你的奶奶机就已经能做到了。
Oh, yeah. Ergo, you saw it 15 fucking years ago. What are you talking about? No, no. No, no, no, but that you can do. Oh, can we meet Peter Jamm? No, that you can, if you think of a response to the computer. Oh, OK.
哦，对。因此，你15年前就看过了。你在说什么呢？不，不。不，不，不，但你可以。哦，我们可以见见彼得·杰姆吗？不，你可以，如果你在心里对电脑做出回应。哦，好吧。
And he heard you. That's it. Let of a response that you got it. Okay. Okay. That's it. Let me move on to another question something current. So you know we were talking earlier about We're gonna kiss it out later. You mean when you read people's brainwaves? Well, I found it fascinating. I saw the segment where the guy was thinking and answer And it popped up on the screen again. Again, the third time is really clear. Hey, Sean, your best robot voice, go quick. He's gonna sing Katy Perry watch. Do you want to play a game of war?
他听到了你的声音。就是这样。对于你得到的反应。好吧。好吧。就这样。让我转到另一个问题，一个当前的问题。所以你知道我们刚才在讨论——我们待会儿再亲热吧。你是说当人们读取别人的脑波时？好吧，我觉得这很迷人。我看到那个片段，那个家伙在脑子里想着答案，然后它又弹到了屏幕上。又是这样，第三次真的很清楚。嘿，肖恩，用你最棒的机器人声音，快来。他要唱凯蒂·佩里的歌了，看着吧。你想玩战争游戏吗？
No. Do you want to play J.S.T.A.K.D.O.? Another 15-year-old. Do you want to play J. Tektop? Another 15-year-old. Jason. Do you want to play a game? That's it. That's it. Just seeing himself up.
不想。你想玩J.S.T.A.K.D.O.吗？又一个15岁的老梗。你想玩J. Tektop吗？又一个15岁的老梗。杰森。你想玩个游戏吗？就是这样。就是这样。他自己在铺垫呢。
This is the voice-over artist here. Let's have it. Do you want to play a game? No matter how I say it, it's just a game. I'm sorry. I tried to do that. Do you want to play a game? Yeah. No matter how I say it, it's just the gayest computer ever. I'm sorry. I tried to do that. Do you want to play a gay?
这是这里的画外音演员。来吧。你想玩个游戏吗？不管我怎么说，这听起来都太基了。抱歉。我试过了。你想玩个游戏吗？对。不管我怎么说，这都是史上最基的电脑。抱歉。我试过了。你想玩个……
Yeah. Okay, yeah, sorry. And what's your best computer voice? I'm sorry, Dave. I just love that. I'll sing again, because it's great. It is great. It's what you really should worry about. But coming back to, there are two things.
对。好吧，是的，抱歉。你最拿手的电脑声音是什么？我很抱歉，戴夫。我太喜欢这个了。我再唱一遍，因为这太棒了。这真的很棒。这才是你真正应该担心的。但回到正题，有两点。
One again, summarize. You need to make sure the machines can actually align their goals with ours, because if you have something much smarter than us, other goals were screwed. It's like playing chess today against the computer that has the goal to win when you have, it's no fun. Well, what's the next, because when somebody says, hey, I, all I picture are those mechanical dogs that walk around.
第一，再次总结。你需要确保机器能够真正让它们的目标与我们的目标保持一致，因为如果你拥有一个远比我们聪明的存在，而它的目标却不同，那我们就彻底完蛋了。就像今天跟一个以赢为目标的电脑下棋一样，当你有——这就没意思了。好吧，那接下来是什么，因为当有人说，嘿，AI，我脑子里浮现的全是那些到处乱走的机械狗。
And they don't really do anything. Just like, oh, look, we invented a robot dog, and it doesn't really do anything. So I want to know, like, what's the next thing that we can use it like that's like mechanical cats? Yeah. Mechanical cats? Yeah, no, you know what I mean? Like, what's the, oh, imagine mechanical cats. Yeah. Yeah, you know what I mean?
它们其实什么也没做。就像，哦，看，我们发明了一只机械狗，但它其实什么也不干。所以我想知道，接下来我们能用它做什么，比如像机械猫之类的东西？对。机械猫？对，不，你知道我的意思吗？比如，哦，想象一下机械猫。对。对，你知道我的意思吗？
Imagine mechanical cats doing cats. Oh my god, we amazing. Sorry, we'll get back. You're saying what's the next thing we can look forward to enjoying out of science? Yeah, in the pop sense. Okay, in the pop sense. So first of all, so just to finish off, we talked about, you know, Hollywood makes us associate AI so much with robots and the Boston Dynamics dogs.
想象一下机械猫做猫的事情。哦天哪，太棒了。抱歉，我们言归正传。你是说接下来我们可以期待从科学中享受到什么新东西？对，在流行文化的意义上。好吧，在流行文化的意义上。所以首先，为了收尾，我们刚才谈到，你知道，好莱坞让我们把人工智能与机器人以及波士顿动力公司的狗联系得太紧密了。
And you should check them dancing, by the way, if you haven't. Dancing dogs? The dancing Boston Dynamics robots. Super cool. But the biggest impact right now AI is having is actually not robots at all. It's just software. I mentioned this, improve the news, the work project we're doing, which is just a little academic thing, but if you think about social media, that's
顺便说一句，如果你们还没看过，真该看看它们跳舞。会跳舞的狗？波士顿动力的机器人跳舞。超级酷。但人工智能目前造成的最大影响其实根本不是机器人。它只是软件。我刚才提到了 Improve the News，这是我们正在做的一个研究项目，虽然只是个学术小项目，但如果你想想社交媒体，那全都是
all about AI. One of the reasons people hate each other so much more in America now is the effect of AI, not AI that had the goal of making people evil, but just had the goal of making people watch as many ads as possible. But the AI was so smart, figuring out how to manipulate people into watching ads that it realized that the best way to do it is to make them really angry and keep showing the more and more extreme stuff until they were so angry they wouldn't just fragment and feel they're really pissed off.
关于人工智能的。美国人现在彼此之间互相关系如此恶劣的原因之一，就是人工智能的影响。这种人工智能的目的不是让人类变邪恶，而只是为了让人们尽可能多地观看广告。但人工智能太聪明了，它摸索出如何操纵人们去看广告，于是意识到最好的方法就是彻底激怒他们，不断向他们展示越来越极端的消极内容，直到他们愤怒到不仅心生分裂，而且觉得极其火大。
You then research that thing even more and then you get more ads and all that stuff. So that's one. All of social media, I mean, yeah. And the other one is, let's talk about positive things because AI intelligence, right? It's human intelligence that's given us everything we like about civilization. So clearly, if we can amplify it with artificial intelligence, we can use it to solve all sorts of problems. We're stumped on now, like cancer and lifting everybody out of poverty and so on.
接着你会花更多时间去搜索那件事，然后就会看到更多广告，诸如此类。所以这是一个。所有的社交媒体，我是说，是的。另一个，我们来谈谈积极的方面，因为人工智能，对吧？正是人类的智慧赋予了我们对文明的一切喜爱。很显然，如果我们能用人工智能来放大这种智慧，我们就能用它解决目前让我们一筹莫展各种问题，比如癌症、让所有人摆脱贫困等等。
Well, there ever be, so we go ahead, sorry. Yeah, no. So I was just going to say, like, another pure software thing that has nothing to do with bots is use AI for doing better science, better medical research. For example. Can I ask about that? So is there any, like I read a long time ago about like, you know, like you put a locator chip in your dog or you cat, whatever, you, I heard that they might be making a chip
好吧，到底会不会有，所以我们接着说，抱歉。是的，没错。所以我本来想说的是，另一个纯软件方面的东西，和机器人毫无关系，那就是利用人工智能来实现更好的科学研究、更好的医学研究。比如说。我能问个问题吗？那么有没有，就像我很久以前读到过的那样，你知道的，就像你在狗或猫身上植入定位芯片一样，无论哪种，我听说他们可能会制造一种芯片，
that has all your medical files and you put it under your skin so you can just scan it because filling out all those fucking forms over and over. It's like, I just, I just filled out the form and now you're asking me the questions all over again. Read the thing, I just got 20 minutes off. I'm not, I'm dying. I'm dying.
里面存有你所有的医疗档案，你把它植入皮下，这样只需扫描一下就行了，因为一遍又一遍地填那些该死的表格太烦了。感觉就像，我刚填完表，现在你们又把那些问题重新问了一遍。看一下资料好吗，我刚刚请了20分钟假。我没，我快死了。我快死了。
Right, I'm like, what? And it's like, what's your name? I just filled three forms out that says what my name. I think I personally get a pass on that ship implant and just ask the hospital to have a less stone age computer system, but the series live course. Did you care about Sean showing up to doctor's appointments late so that he doesn't have to wait?
对啊，我想，什么？然后就问，你叫什么名字？我刚刚才填了三张表，上面都写了我的名字。我觉得我个人可以免除植入这种芯片，只要让医院换一套不那么像石器时代的电脑系统就行了，不过这也是系列节目的一部分。你在意肖恩去看医生时迟到，好不用排队这件事吗？
It's riveting. I don't know if that's AI or whatever. Something huge that happened this year, for example, is biologists have spent 50 years trying to figure out just from the DNA how the shape is going to turn out to be of different proteins that our bodies make. It's called a protein folding problem. And then Google DeepMind solved it. No way.
这太吸引人了。我不知道这算不算人工智能什么的。今年发生的一件大事，比如，生物学家们花 了50 年时间，试图仅仅根据DNA来弄清楚我们体内产生的各种蛋白质会呈现出什么样的形状。这被称为蛋白质折叠问题。然后谷歌DeepMind解决了它。不可能。
Yeah, with an AI. And now you can develop medicines faster. So this is a fantastic example, I think, of AI for good. Another one. But then the robots that are having probably that are going to have the biggest effect, I think, on us and the job market in the next five years, are probably cars, actually.
是的，通过人工智能。现在你可以更快地开发药物了。所以我觉得这是一个极好的例子，证明了人工智能造福人类。另一个例子是。但接下来可能会对我们以及未来五年的就业市场产生最大影响的机器人，实际上可能是汽车。
This is autonomous vehicles. That's pretty cool. I'm worried about everybody with their cars and the automatic driving or whatever, and then they show up, and then people just gonna show up at the valley, like dead in their car. It's gonna be really, you know what I mean? Like people are gonna get in their car,
这就是自动驾驶汽车。这挺酷的。我很担心每个人都开着车，或者自动驾驶之类的，然后他们到了地方，人们结果却发现代客泊车的人死在了车里。这会很诡异，你知道我的意思吗？就像人们坐进车里，
and then they're gonna be like, the pizza guy shows up, and he's like slumped over. You're open the door. They're open the door. Yeah, just out. You know what I mean? Like that's what I'm worried about. Now, with the combination of what you know about computers,
然后会发现，送披萨的家伙来了，他整个人瘫倒在方向盘上。你打开车门。他们打开车门。对，直接倒出来了。你知道我的意思吗？这就是我所担心的事情。现在，结合你对计算机的了解、
what you know about space, what you know about intelligence, I know, I know what you want to know. You know what I'm asking for? Yes, John wants to know. He wants to know if there's aliens, but we're not going to ask him that. No, not that. What I think is something about you.
你对太空的了解、你对智能的了解，我懂，我知道你想知道什么。你知道我在问什么吗？是的，约翰想知道。他想知道有没有外星人，但我们不会问他这个。不，不是那个。我觉得是关于你的一些事。
What I want to know from you is, is it based on your knowledge of all those areas, does it seem possible to you that there is the requisite amount of intelligence and technology at a place other than Earth? Ooh, see, he asks, is it a different way than I would? Well, of course, he's a different way than I would. Well, of course it's possible, although, you know, my guess, based on spending a lot of years dealing with telescopes and thinking about these things is that when we, for the first time, get way more advanced technological intelligence showing up on this planet, it's probably going to be in our lifetime, and
我想从你这里知道的是，根据你对所有这些领域的知识，在你看来，在地球以外的地方，是否存在必要数量的智能和技术是可能的？哦，你看，他问的方式跟我可不一样！好吧，当然，他问的方式跟我不同。好吧，当然是有可能的，尽管你知道，根据我多年来研究望远镜和思考这些问题的经验，我的猜测是，当我们第一次发现地球上出现更加先进的技术智能时，那很可能在我们有生之年发生，而且
it's probably not going to come from outer space. It's going to be something we built. What do you mean? What do you mean? So you're saying maybe, when you're building something to bring them here, what do you say? No, I mean, we're basically, if the goal of artificial intelligence has always been to build stuff that's part of that.
它可能不会来自外太空。它将是我们自己建造的东西。你什么意思？你什么意思？你是说也许，当你建造某种东西把他们带到这里来时，你在说什么？不，我的意思是，我们基本上，如果人工智能的目标一直是制造属于那一部分的东西。
Yeah, they just don't have cars. They need to get here. So you're basically, oh, they're basically going to be dead when they get here? No way, keep going. So we're really, if you basically build a new species, a new life form, that's way, way smarter than us. Yeah. Right?
对，他们只是没有车。他们需要来到这里。所以你基本上，哦，他们到这里的时候基本上已经死了？不会吧，继续说。所以我们真的，如果你基本上创造了一个新物种、一种新的生命形式，它比我们聪明得多、多得多。
Yeah. That's alien. That's alien. That's incredibly alien. It's much more different from a chipmunk or a tiger and that it really has nothing in common with our evolutionary history. Nothing doesn't necessarily care even about food
对吧？没错。那就是外星生命。那就是外星生命。那是极其外星的。它与花栗鼠或老虎有很大不同，因为它与我们的进化史没有任何共同之处。它甚至完全不在乎食物
or reproducing itself. So if we do that, it's going to be just as big an event on Earth as if aliens show up. And that's why I'm kind of weirded out that people talk so little bit about this. That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying. As despicable as human beings were all, and gloomy, everybody,
或是自我复制。所以如果我们这样做了，它在地球上引发的轰动将不亚于外星人降临。这就是为什么我对人们对这件事讨论得这么少感到有点不可思议。这就是我想说的。这就是我想说的。尽管人类是多么的卑鄙，大家都，阴郁啊，每个人，
we're just so despicable that if the announcement came that like, oh my God, there are aliens from there, they're visiting our planet, people be like, oh, okay, I gotta check my Instagram. Like, I don't think people would be like, give it to me. Based on that, it seems to me that what you would wanna do is make sure that somehow built in all this stuff is some kind of a kill switch.
我们就是如此卑鄙，以至于如果传来这样的公告，比如，天哪，有外星人来了，他们正在访问我们的星球，人们会反应说，哦，好吧，我去刷一下Instagram。就像，我觉得人们不会表现得像，快告诉我吧。基于此，在我看来，你想做的事是确保在所有这些东西里面都内置某种类似于紧急停止开关的东西。
And that the wise men who are, and women, you know what I mean, but like a group, right? Probably made up of you and your other colleagues, male or female from around the world that are the leading scientists in this area would get together on some encrypted platform and say, let's make sure we only us five know about this one thing
而且那些智者，无论是男是女，你知道我的意思，但就像一个群体，对吧？很可能是由你和你的其他男女同事组成，他们来自世界各地，是这个领域的顶尖科学家，他们会聚集在某个加密平台上说，让我们确保只有我们五个人知道这唯一的一件事，
that we could press to shut all these AI robots down that we've created on our way. I'll be one, I won't tell anybody. I won't tell anybody. All four kill switches, all of this is what I do. I know, let's find bar room. This sounds a little too, let me just for me, because the idea that somehow,
我们可以按下它来关闭我们创造的所有这些人工智能机器人。我会当其中一个，我不会告诉任何人。我不会告诉任何人。所有四个紧急开关，这都是我干的。我知道，让我们找个酒吧。这听起来有点太，让我自己来，因为这种想法，
you know, I wish I had a dude who were like, no, a lot about AI, he should decide, humanity's future. That's kind of how, I wanted in your hands. But that's how it is now, you know, if we don't, if the rest of us, everybody doesn't get engaged in these things, who's gonna make all these decisions?
你知道，我希望我能有一个精通人工智能的家伙，他来决定人类的未来。有点像是，我希望它掌握在你们手中。但现在情况就是这样，你知道的，如果我们不这样做，如果我们其余的人、每个人都不参与到这些事情中来，谁来做所有这些决定？
It's gonna be probably a bunch of dudes in some back room or some who have not been elected. Are people who are super AI nerds like specialists in what human happiness is? Only they would know the ramifications of something getting in the wrong hands. But are they the ones who should be deciding what makes them not some elected weirdo? Yeah. So I don't trust particularly elected people, but I also don't trust tech nerds with being experts in psychology and what they're like.
那可能是一群在某个后屋里的家伙，或者某些没有经选举产生的人。或者那些超级人工智能书呆子，比如人类幸福感方面的专家？只有他们才知道某些东西落入坏人之手会产生什么后果。但他们应该是决定因素吗？不应该是一个经过选举产生的怪胎吗？是的。所以我不信任特别由选举产生的人，但我也同样不信任那些自诩为心理学专家和了解人类的技术极客。
Who can we trust? Then we got to show them the best. Everybody. I mean, they should trust it to the nerds. What are you talking about? Talk about. Talk about it. I'm going to ask you guys, suppose you have a magic wand that you can wave, okay, and
我们可以相信谁？然后我们得给他们展示最好的一面。所有人。我是说，他们应该把这交给书呆子。你在说什么？胡说八道。我们要问你们一个问题，假设你们有一根可以挥舞的魔杖，好吗，
create this future 35 years from now, okay? When there is this very advanced AI, and you get to decide how the planet is organized, what it's used for, and what it's not used for. So it's not gonna be your standard dystopian Hollywood flick. What is this future like? What do you want it to be like?
创造出35年后的这个未来，好吗？当拥有了这种非常先进的人工智能，而你可以决定这个星球是如何组织的、它被用于什么、不被用于什么。所以它不会是你标准的好莱坞反乌托邦电影。这个未来是什么样的？你希望它变成什么样？
Well, that makes me want to take a nap. Oh. Well, you want me want to take a nap. Well, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, you would, You point it all in that direction, and then good decisions come from that. I don't know. Yes. Brave New World. Yeah. Well, that sounds great. So it's a frighteningly expected response.
好吧，这让我想小睡一会儿。哦。好吧，你想让我小睡一会儿。好吧，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你本来会，你前回车，把这一切都指向那个方向，然后好的决策就会随之而来。我不知道。是的。美丽新世界。好吧。听起来很棒。所以这是一个令人恐惧的意料之中的回答。
Let's compare that with what we're most extending AI money on now, right? So a massive amount of money is spent on advertising, you end up making teenage girls on a rexick, and then we have a massive amount of enormous amount of money now building robots to kill people. For the first time, they were used in Libya last year. They hunted down these fleeing people and just killed them because the robots decided that they were probably bad guys. And I think- I did not know about that.
让我们把它与我们现在在人工智能上花钱最多的领域进行比较，对吧？所以大量的资金被花在广告上，结果让十几岁的女孩患上厌食症，然后我们现在又花巨资制造杀人机器人。去年，它们首次在利比亚被使用。它们追捕这些逃亡的人并将他们直接击毙，因为机器人判定这些人可能是坏人。我觉得-我之前不知道这件事。
It's- I don't know. Did you guys all know about that? About's a... I don't know. Did you guys all know about that? About the robots and hundreds of people down? Yeah, let's not gloss over that. What happened? This is the shit that I'm talking about, man.
这-我不知道。你们大家都知道这件事吗？关于-我不知道。你们大家都知道这件事吗？关于机器人追捕人们的事？是的，我们别轻描淡写地把这事带过。到底怎么回事？这就是我一直在说的那些狗屁倒灶的事，老兄。
Yeah, so it's... It actually has some dark comedic value, I think. Yeah, that's hilarious. The current policy, actually actually of the US government on killer robots and slaughterbots is three things. First of all, the US says, you know, these are murder hornets. First of all, we're saying this is nasty stuff that we don't ever want to delegate kill decisions to machines.
是的，所以它...我觉得这其实带有一种黑色幽默的价值。是的，太搞笑了吧。美国政府目前对杀人机器人和屠杀机器人的政策实际上有三点。首先，美国说，你知道的，这些都是“杀人黄蜂”。首先，我们说这是恶劣的东西，我们绝不想把杀人的决定委托给机器。
So we're not going to do it. Second, it's going to have a decisive impact on the battlefield. And third, we're going to reserve the right for all other countries to build them and export them to whoever they want. So like this was this Turkish company decided to sell them to Libya against the arms embargo and that's why they hunted these people down. We went like a really short span.
所以我们不会这么做。其次，它将对战场产生决定性的影响。第三，我们要保留所有其他国家制造它们并将它们出口给他们想出口的任何人的权利。所以就像这家土耳其公司决定无视武器禁运将它们卖给利比亚一样，这就是为什么它们会追捕这些人。我们在很短的时间内，
We went from replicating a sheep to slaughterbots. Like it seems like that happened really quickly. Yeah, man. And so is there, we had a, we were talking to a guest earlier today about time travel. And now, so it's on, it's on our minds. Now, and'm not... And we do have to ask you, like we did before,
就从克隆一只绵羊跨越到了屠杀机器人。这一切似乎发生得太快了。是的，老兄。那么，我们今天早些时候和一位嘉宾谈论过时间旅行。现在，这事儿在我们脑子里了。现在，我不是...我们不得不问你，就像之前一样，
if you're good to, did you time travel here? I do. If... If... Is there any chance... And I won't bore you with the same question that I asked that astronomer that we had about the mirrors... At the rest, I said.
如果你愿意，你是通过时间旅行来到这里的吗？我是。如果...如果有任何机会...而且我不会用我之前问那个关于镜子的天文学家时提过的同样问题来烦你...我当时说的是...
It was a real highlight. Oh, no. But, yeah. But in the... No, because we'll try here. So, the... Will said, Neil the Grass Tyson was on. And Jason asked a really long question
那绝对是个亮点。哦，不。但是，是的。但是在...不，因为我们会在这里尝试。所以，威尔说，奈尔·德加斯·泰森曾来过。然后杰森问了一个非常长的问题，
and about time travel. And Will said, Hey, do you think we could put enough mirrors and go travel back in time to the beginning of Jason's question? But... And it's a valid... It's hard for me. It's question. And it's a valid. It's hard for me.
关于时间旅行。然后威尔说，嘿，你觉得我们能摆足够多的镜子，然后回到杰森提问的开头吗？但是...这是一个合理的...对我来说很难。这个问题。这是一个合理的...对我来说很难。
It's a valid. It's a valid. So the light we get from the sun has been traveling seven minutes. Eight minutes. Eight minutes. OK. So we're basically feeling something that's eight minutes old. We're back on this.
这是一个合理的...这是一个合理的...所以我们从太阳收到的光已经旅行了七分钟。八分钟。八分钟。好吧。所以我们感受到的基本上是八分钟前的景象。我们又回到这个话题了。
That's right. That's right. Right? OK. So isn't there a way to have a mirror that creates anyway? Yes, actually. There is. Well hang on, there is.
没错。没错。对吧？好吧。那难道没有什么方法可以弄一面能创造出什么的镜子吗？是的，实际上。有的。等等，有的。
He says yes. He likes my thinking. I'm sure it will be built for us actually. In the middle of our galaxy, there's this monster black hole that weighs about four million times as much as a sun. And it's black. Oh, that's mine. Oh, no, it's a black hole.
他说有。他喜欢我的思路。我敢打赌这实际上会为我们建造出来。在我们银河系的中心，有一个庞大的黑洞，它的质量大约是太阳的四百万倍。它是黑色的。哦，那是我的。哦，不，那是个黑洞。
Okay. And if you look at it purely carefully, light that went from you actually was bent by its gravity so much that it comes back on the other side of the black hole. Like, to mirror. So if you look at the really good telescope, in principle, you could see your own reflection, except no way, no way, no way, no way, no way, no way,
好的。如果你极其仔细地观察它，从你身上发出的光实际上会被它的引力极大地弯曲，以至于它会从黑洞的另一侧折射回来。就像，当成一面镜子。所以如果你用一个非常好的望远镜观察，原则上，你可以看到你自己的倒影，除了没门，没门，没门，没门，没门，没门，
that you weren't born yet. Are you serious? Oh, wait, so Tom. And now, a word from her sponsor. Since his death in 2009, the world has struggled with how Michael Jackson should be remembered as the King of Pop or as a monster. I'm Leon Nefak, the host of Fiasco
你当时还没出生呢。你是认真的吗？哦，等等，那么汤姆。现在，听一段赞助商信息。自从2009年去世以来，世界一直在争论应该如何铭记迈克尔·杰克逊：是作为流行音乐之王，还是作为一个恶魔。我是里昂·内法克，《Fiasco》的主持人，
and the co-creator of Slow Burn. And I'm Jay Smooth, a hip-hop journalist and cultural commentator. Michael Jackson was accused of child molestation for the first time in 1993. Our new podcast Think Twice, Michael Jackson, is the story of what came before and what came after. Throughout the podcast, we explore what makes Michael Jackson seemingly uncancelable. And we dig into the complicated feelings so many of us have when we hear Billie Jean at the grocery store. Through dozens of original interviews with people who watched the story unfold firsthand, think twice as an attempt to reconcile our conflicted
也是《Slow Burn》的共同创作者。我是杰伊·斯穆斯，一位嘻哈记者和文化评论员。迈克尔·杰克逊在1993年首次被指控猥亵儿童。我们的新播客《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》讲述的是事件发生之前和之后的故事。在整个播客中，我们探讨了是什么让迈克尔·杰克逊似乎永远不会被“取消”。我们深入探讨了许多人在杂货店听到《比利·简》时产生的复杂情感。通过对亲历这一事件的人们进行的数十次独家采访，《三思》试图将我们对迈克尔·杰克逊这个人的矛盾情感，
emotions about Michael Jackson, the man with our deep-seated love of his art. Listen to think twice, Michael Jackson, wherever you get your podcasts, or you can binge the entire series ad-free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music app. And now, back to the show. Wait, so talk, go. So that's basically time to, in other words, these telescopes, like the one we just launched up the web. They're looking so far back, they might actually see the big bang at some point, or something
与我们对他的艺术的深切热爱调和起来。在您获取播客的任何地方收听《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》，或者您可以在 Audible 或 Amazon Music 应用程序上免广告畅听整个系列。现在，回到节目中。等等，那么，谈，继续。所以这基本上是时间，换句话说，这些望远镜，比如我们刚刚发射上去的韦伯望远镜。它们看得太远了，以至于在某个时刻它们甚至可能看到大爆炸，或者某个
we're seeing the galaxy at an earlier stage than us. So eventually, if you get a telescope strong enough, you could see the start of Earth potentially, so it came all came out a big thing. We should tell you, we all took mushrooms before. All right, it's just from the beginning. Yeah, and we were so interested. Somewhere in there is there an answer about
我们正在观测处于更早期阶段的星系。所以最终，如果你拥有一台足够强大的望远镜，理论上你可以看到地球的起源，因为它都是从大爆炸中诞生的。我们应该告诉你们，我们之前都嗑了蘑菇。好了，从头开始吧。是的，我们当时太感兴趣了。其中某个地方会不会有关于
a lot of hot pot. Some of us took a double. A possibility of time travel. Yeah, so this is a kind of sea, but not touch time travel. OK. The sky is a kind of sea, but not touch time travel. Okay. The sky is a time machine, just like that. You see me, three minutes, not time travel.
一锅热汤的答案。我们有些人吃了双倍剂量。时间旅行的可能性。是的，所以这是一种看得到却摸不着的时间旅行。好吧。天空是一种看得到却摸不着的时间旅行。好吧。天空就是一个时间机器，就像那样。你看到我，那是三纳秒前，不是时间旅行。
Yeah, three nanoseconds ago, you see the sun, eight minutes ago, you see stars at night, if it's clear, so along go the people over there looking at us would see maybe the Boston Tea Party, and we can see things that happen over 13 billion years ago. You can also travel forward in time for real. I know bullshit, real time travel. You go to this blockhole here. That's my...
是的，三纳秒前，你看到的是太阳，八分钟前，如果天气晴朗，你看到的是夜空中的星星，同样，那边看着我们的人可能会看到波士顿倾茶事件，而我们可以看到1亿多年前发生的事情。你还可以真正地在时间里向前旅行。我知道这是废话，真正的时空旅行。你去这个黑洞这里。那是我的...
I was told, actually, when I moved to the US, that America possession is 95% of the law. I think. Is that true? You know what? Now it's yours. So anyway, if you just orbit around this black hole really close, which you can actually do, I give this as a homework problem to my MIT students, then your time will actually slow down so much that if you're on Skype with you, you'll be hearing him go like, hello, I'm
事实上，我搬到美国时被告知，占有即95%的法律。我想。是这样吗？你知道吗？现在它是你的了。所以不管怎样，如果你绕着这个黑洞非常近地运行，这其实是办得到的，我把这作为家庭作业布置给我的麻省理工学院学生，那么你的时间实际上会变慢如此之多，以至于如果你在跟别人用Skype通话，你会听到他说：“喂，我——”
here. And then you're gonna hear him say, oh my God, that's a word of the word, what's going on there? Well, that's accurate. Because, we're times are actually running at different rates. And then when you come back, you look so good, so useful.
在这里。然后你会听到他说：“哦，天哪，那是怎么回事，那边出什么事了？”好吧，这很准确。因为，时间实际上以不同的速率在流逝。然后当你回来时，你看上去状态大好，如此年轻。
Because you're actually younger than, yes, yes, you would have been otherwise. So are we gonna be alive when we start to see any of this stuff that's gonna really blow our minds? Yeah, and Mars, are we living on Mars, go. So this is an upside of artificial intelligence. Roll that window, no.
因为你实际上比，是的，是的，如果没有这样的话，你要年轻得多。那么，在我们有生之年，我们能活着看到任何这些真正让我们大开眼界的东西吗？是的，还有火星，我们能在火星上生活吗，继续。所以这是人工智能积极的一面。把那个窗户摇下来，不。
That's not a follow-up, it's a different subject. By the way, you mentioned before, Boston's in party too soon, you know. This is the upside of artificial intelligence, no. It's just for us too, though, huh? This is the last. This is the upside of artificial intelligence, because either just for us, too, so what? This is the last. This is the upside of artificial intelligence. Either we can use it to go extinct in our lifetime
这不是后续问题，这是个新话题。顺便说一句，你刚才提到波士顿倾茶事件太早了，你知道的。这是人工智能积极的一面，不。不过这也是为了我们好，对吧？这是最后。这是人工智能积极的一面。要么我们可以利用它让我们在有生之年灭绝，
or we can use it to bring all these awesome things about in our lifetime. We used to think, oh, this is going to take 10,000 years to get like the sci-fi novels, because we humans have to figure out all the tech ourselves. No. If we can build this incredibly advanced AI that can then build more advanced AI, et cetera, et cetera,
要么我们可以利用它在我们的有生之年带来所有这些了不起的事物。我们过去常常认为，哦，要达到科幻小说里的水平需要一万年，因为我们人类必须自己搞定所有的技术。不。如果我们能够建造出这种极其先进的人工智能，然后它又可以建造更先进的人工智能，以此类推，
we might be able to build this tech, you know, 30, 40 years from now. Right. And suddenly, we're not limited by our own pace of developing tech. We just go, boom, and we're limited by the laws of physics. Well, and by the laws of ethics, like if just because we can, should we?
我们也许能够在30、40年内就造出这种技术。没错。突然之间，我们不再受限于自己开发技术的速度。我们只需“轰”的一声，然后我们就只受制于物理定律了。嗯，还有伦理定律，比如，仅仅因为我们能做到，我们就应该去做吗？
Like, how do we know when we, as a society, are mature enough to handle some of the technology that we can, should we? Like how do we know when we as a society are mature enough to handle some of the technology that we can access? I think going and having some fun, joy riding around black holes is ethically okay. Yeah. It's my inner nerd speaking here. As long as you don't force other people to go with you.
就像，我们怎么知道我们作为一个社会是否足够成熟，能够应对我们所能接触到的一些技术？我们就应该去做吗？就像我们怎么知道作为一个社会，我们是否足够成熟，可以掌控我们所能接触到的一些技术？我觉得去黑洞附近兜风、找点乐子，在伦理上是没问题的。是的。这是我内心的极客在说话。只要你不强迫别人跟你一起去。
But on the other hand, that's one of the- No, man, don't be nervous, just go into the black hole. So, like, we're not forcing, but it is peer pressure. The- The- The- That's one of the questions that they asked in Jurassic Park was just- Yeah, good Jurassic Park, good. Yes, I'm not-
但另一方面，那是其中一个——不，老兄，别紧张，直接进黑洞吧。所以，就像，我们没有强迫，但这是同辈压力。那——那——那是《侏罗纪公园》里提出的问题之一——是的，很好的《侏罗纪公园》，很好。是的，我不是——
I'm not- Yes, I'm not. Just because- Keep on the science. Just because you can create this island with these dinosaurs, Yes. Should you? Now, the- Because you can create this island with these dinosaurs. Yes. Should you?
我不是——是的，我不是。仅仅因为——坚持科学。仅仅因为你可以用这些恐龙创造这个岛屿，是的。你就应该这么做吗？现在，因为你可以用这些恐龙创造这个岛屿。是的。你就应该这么做吗？
Right. Based on the science of that, the amber that was frozen in there with the DNA of the dinosaurs, is that real? Yes. Is that real? Well, now, you know, we have my friend George Church, down in Harvard here, he's talking about already bringing back the mammoth by just taking the DNA together assembling it error correcting a scooter than
对。根据那里的科学，保存在琥珀中、带有恐龙DNA的东西，那是真的吗？是的。那是真的吗？好吧，现在，你知道的，我们在哈佛的朋友乔治·查奇，他已经在谈论通过获取DNA、将其组装、纠错，然后
Basically DNA printing out the mammoth DNA and boom mammoth. We can do a lot of these things Leaving we can come back to the ethical question. They're just thing him exactly who's what's the what's the key? Which is name again George church? What's the one to show? What's the count? That's all that's gonna say yes or no? Let me just say a bigger thing first though, just to get the controversy out of the way, you know. I think we humans to really get the ethical decisions right and let people forfeit some dumb stuff. You have to remember how much upside there is also.
基本上通过DNA打印出猛犸象的DNA，然后——轰，猛犸象。我们可以做很多这样的事情。我们可以回头再探讨伦理问题。刚才那个人叫什么名字来着？乔治·查奇？哪个节目？哪个账号？这就是我要说的，是还是不是？不过首先让我讲一件更大的事，好把争议抛开，你知道的。我认为人类要真正做出正确的伦理决策，并让人类放弃一些愚蠢的事情，你必须记住这里有多少积极的方面。
We're living on this little spinning ball in space where they almost ate billion people on it and been spending so many years killing each other over a little bit more sand here and a little more forest there. Where in this huge universe, right? We thought was off-limits? Well, with AI, it could be on-limits again. We could go to the Alpha Centauri system in a lifetime.
我们生活在太空中这个旋转的小球上，上面有将近八亿人，却花了这么多年的时间为了这里的一点沙子和那里的一点森林而互相残杀。而在如此巨大的宇宙中，对吧？我们以为那是禁区？好吧，有了人工智能，它可能又变成可以涉足的领域了。我们可以在有生之年去到半人马座阿尔法星系。
We could have a future where life is flourishing in our galaxy and in our other galaxies, where there's such an amazing abundance that people are going to be wondering, why did these guys fudge around for so many years in this little planet and fight squabble about breadcrumbs instead of going on? Most of this universe, despite all the Star Trek episodes out there No offense So far really don't seem to have woken up and come alive in any major way And I feel that we humans
我们可以拥有这样一个未来：生命在我们的银河系和其他银河系中蓬勃发展，那里有如此惊人的富足，以至于人们会纳闷，为什么这些家伙在这个小行星上浑浑噩噩地混了这么多年，为了面包屑争吵不休，而不是继续前进？这个宇宙的大部分地方，尽管有那么多的《星际迷航》剧集——无意冒犯——到目前为止似乎真的还没有以任何重大方式苏醒并活跃起来。我觉得我们人类
Have a more or less responsibility to see if we can help life It more our universe wake up some more and help life spread Well, what if we run out of time with our use on this planet because of environment where we don't I'm reading your mind. Yeah, we're getting to Mars. So can we point the AI to our challenges here regarding the environment, fix that real quick, and then we can explore everywhere else? I think we need to fix things here in parallel. The reason that the main forest is partly gone, the reason we're messing up our climate and so many other things isn't because we didn't know 10 years ago what to do about it. It's because we kind of already built another kind of AI, these very powerful systems,
或多或少有责任看看我们是否能帮助生命在我们的宇宙中更多地苏醒并帮助生命传播。好吧，如果我们因为环境问题而在我们在这个星球上的时间耗尽，我们没有——我猜到你的心思了。是的，我们要去火星。所以我们能否把人工智能对准我们这里关于环境的挑战，快速解决它，然后我们就可以探索其他地方了？我认为我们需要同时解决这里的问题。雨林部分消失的原因，我们把气候和其他许多事情搞砸的原因，并不是因为我们10年前不知道该怎么做。而是因为我们实际上已经建造了另一种人工智能，这些非常强大的系统，
corporations, governments, et cetera, that have goals that aren't so aligned with the rainforest and maybe the overall goal is of. If we can use the AI to tell them how they can make more profit doing things that aren't so aligned with the rainforest, then maybe the overall goal is over. If we can use the AI to tell them how they can make more profit doing things that don't kill the earth, then they'll stop chopping down the forest. Well, maybe we should take the biggest step back, you know, the whole point of having, I mean, you've got stock and exon, don't you?
公司、政府等，它们的目标与雨林并不那么一致，也许总体目标是——如果我们能利用人工智能告诉它们，如何通过做那些对雨林不那么有害的事情来获得更多利润，那么也许总体目标就完成了。如果我们能利用人工智能告诉它们，如何通过不做那些毁灭地球的事情来获得更多利润，那么它们就会停止砍伐森林。好吧，也许我们应该退后最大的一步，你知道的，拥有这一切的全部意义，我的意思是，你有埃克森美孚的股票，对吧？
He's not comfortable answering this. My undergrad was an economics. So I am very sympathetic to the free market. You're doing things more efficient. But the whole point of the free market is that you should get done efficiently things that you want to get done. And then you should have, of course, some guidelines.
他对回答这个问题感到不自在。我的本科专业是经济学。所以我非常同情自由市场。让事情更有效率。但自由市场的全部意义在于，你应该高效地完成你想完成的事情。然后，你当然应该有一些指导方针。
That's why we decided to ban Shia labor in the US. That's why we decided to invent the shy labor in the US. That's why we decided to invent the weekend. So, you know, you don't like the weekend? I think you said it's very stressful. But right now, we have, if you create something, you know, whether it be a super powerful dictatorship or it beats the, you know, the back-hole company that tries to convince you that cancer, that smoking isn't dangerous, or whatever. It has its own goals, and it's going to act.
这就是为什么我们决定在美国禁止童工。这就是为什么我们决定在美国发明童工。这就是为什么我们决定发明周末。所以，你知道的，你不喜欢周末？我想你说过这压力很大。但现在我们拥有，如果你创造了某种东西，你知道的，无论是超级强大的独裁者，还是击败了——你知道的——那个试图让你相信癌症、吸烟并不危险等等的黑洞公司。它有它自己的目标，而且它会付诸行动。
It's good to think of these things a little bit like an AI, even though it's not made out of robots. It's made of people. Because there's no person in a back of a company that's consignal-handedly change its goals, right? If the CEO decides to stop selling cigarettes, he's just going to get fired, right? So we should start thinking about how do we just align the incentives of all the companies. I want to keep private companies incentives of people and incentives of companies and incentives of politicians with the incentives of humanity itself to get what you were asking for, you know, as a society in the future where we work.
把这些事情想象成有点像人工智能是个不错的办法，尽管它不是由机器人构成的。它是由人构成的。因为公司内部没有人能够单方面改变它的目标，对吧？如果CEO决定停止销售香烟，他就会被解雇，对吧？所以我们应该开始思考，我们如何才能将所有公司的激励机制——我想保持私营企业的激励机制，即人们的激励机制、公司的激励机制以及政客的激励机制——与人类本身的激励机制对齐，从而获得你所要求的，你知道的，作为一个社会在未来的工作方式。
The change is more cultural rather than scientific if you will. Yeah, although you do need to kick out a bit a lot about the whole business within incentives. Like, why did we invent the legal system in the US? Well, because we realize it's not so smart that people always kill each other every time they get into a squabble about a hot dog, right? Right, so a consequence. So you change consequences and not only think twice, and they'll just punch each other instead, or have said lippons or other way.
这种改变更多是文化上的，而不是科学上的，如果你这么说的话。是的，尽管你确实需要对整个商业内部的激励机制进行大量深入的思考。比如，我们为什么要在美国发明法律系统？嗯，因为我们意识到，人们每次在热狗问题上争吵不休时就互相厮杀，这并不那么明智，对吧？对吧，所以要有后果。所以你要改变后果，而不仅仅是三思而后行，否则他们就会转而互殴，或者采用其他鞭笞或别的方式。
We, we, alignment is kind of the big slogan a lot of us nerds have for this. You want to align the incentives not just the machines but also the organizations with what's actually good for humanity. And we're in this unfortunate situation now where whenever an entity gets too powerful, it doesn't have to be a machine or a dictator, it could even be a company, that they start to now like take over whoever was supposed to regulate them, and turn them into like a rubber stop. Now there's suddenly not going to be so lined with what's good for America anymore, or good for humanity.
我们，我们，“对齐”是我们这些书呆子经常挂在嘴边的一个宏大口号。你不仅要让机器的激励机制与对人类真正有益的事情保持一致，还要让组织的激励机制保持一致。我们现在处于这种不幸的境地：每当一个实体变得过于强大（它不一定非得是机器或独裁者，甚至可以是一家公司），它们现在就会开始接管任何本该监管它们的人，并将他们变成橡皮图章。现在他们突然不再与对美国有益或对人类有益的事情保持高度一致了。
And this problem, we cannot wait for AI to solve it. We have to start solving that in the meantime. Amen. But you know, I mean, that's been the modus operandi up till now. And we are running out of time. And people are taking their profits because they figured they're going to be dead before the ramifications of it really.
而这个问题，我们不能等待人工智能来解决。我们必须在此期间开始解决这个问题。阿门。但你知道，我的意思是，这就是一直以来的行事方式。而且我们的时间不多了。人们在攫取利润，因为他们觉得自己在这个问题的后果真正显现之前就已经死了。
Like, so I think the computers have to help us out. Yes, yes, absolutely. So this is why I'm so into this AI empowerment thing. I want to think about how can we use AI and put it into the hands of people so that they can very easily like catch other powerful entities that are trying to screw them over. And it's a way of using technology to strengthen democracy. Are we going to live on the moon at all? You want to? Yeah.
所以我觉得计算机必须来帮我们一把。是的，是的，绝对的。这就是为什么我如此热衷于人工智能赋能这件事。我想思考的是，我们如何才能利用人工智能并把它交到普通人手中，这样他们就能非常容易地抓住其他试图坑害他们的强大实体。这是利用技术来强化民主的一种方式。我们以后会在月球上生活吗？你想去吗？是的。
Is that possible? Are we planning on that? Would you want to? Should I believe that? Do you want to? Yeah, I would totally live there. All of these things are certainly possible. I was very much of the opinion that it's easier to make a really comfortable and pleasant life on this planet.
那可能吗？我们在计划这件事吗？你想去吗？我该相信吗？你想去吗？是的，我完全愿意住在那里。所有这些事情当然都是可能的。我非常赞成这样的观点：在这个星球上创造一个真正舒适愉快的生活要容易得多。
So I would also like to make sure I don't ruin it. Is there one project that you're working on right now, just one that you feel extremely passionate about right now that you could share with us? It's actually improvenews.org. This thing I mentioned earlier. It's called improvenews.org. Improve the news.org. It's just this free little news aggregator,
所以我同样希望确保我不会毁了它。有没有哪个项目是你现在正在进行的，仅仅一个，你现在对它充满了无限热情，可以跟我们分享一下的？其实就是 improvenews.org。就是我刚才提到的那个。它叫 improvenews.org。Improve the News.org。它只是一个免费的小型新闻聚合器，
but it's all powered by machine learning. So that's why it can actually read 5,000 new article every day, which I can. I saw that in that out. And then what we're doing is, instead of just saying, OK, today we have a lot of news sites. You can go there and read about all the good things that Democrats have done and all the bad things
但它完全由机器学习驱动。这就是为什么它实际上每天可以阅读5000篇新文章，这是我做不到的。我在那个应用里看到了。然后我们在做的是，我们不会说，好吧，今天有很多新闻网站。你可以去那里阅读民主党人做过所有好事以及所有坏事，
Republicans have done. And then there are other ones where you can read about all the great things that Republicans have done and how the bad things Republicans have done. And then there are other ones where you can read about all the great things the Republicans have done and how the bad things Democrats have done. Where this one, the AI figures out which articles are about the same story. Maybe it finds now 62 things about the new US national debt passing 30 trillion or whatever.
还有共和党人做过的坏事。然后还有其他网站，你可以阅读共和党人做过所有伟大的事以及共和党人做过的坏事。然后还有其他网站，你可以阅读共和党人做过所有伟大的事以及民主党人做过的坏事。而这个网站，人工智能会找出哪些文章是关于同一个故事的。也许它现在发现了关于美国国债突破30万亿或诸如此类事情的62篇报道。
And then it's like, OK, then you can come in and say, OK, here are the facts that all the articles agree on. Boom, boom, boom. If you're a fact kind of guy, you can now click away say, okay, here are the facts that all the articles agree on. Boom, boom, boom. If you're a fact kind of guy, you can now click away and go to the next story. But if you want to know all the narratives, it separates out. Here is what's the best narrative, that narrative. So you have photos, would it have a photo of Will last January 6th? You mean in the capital?
然后它就会显示，好的，你可以进来然后说，好的，这里是所有文章都一致认同的事实。轰，轰，轰。如果你是一个只看重事实的人，你现在可以点开并转到下一个故事。但如果你想了解所有的叙述方式，它会将其分离开来。这里是最佳叙述，那是那种叙述。所以你有照片，会有威尔去年1月6日的照片吗？你是说在国会大厦里？
I got a little one. You got a little one. No way, with the goggles, to go with the goggles. Yeah. And the thing, there's no way you're getting that photo. How much will you pay me again? Yeah. What's best wordle score? Go.
我有一张小照片。你有一张小照片。不可能，戴着护目镜的那张，戴着护目镜的。对。还有那个东西，你绝对弄不到那张照片。你到底愿意付我多少钱？对。最好的Wordle成绩是什？快说。
And be careful. He got an unbeatable score today. Got it in two. This guy. Not bad. Yeah. Not bad. That sounds amazing.
小心点。他今天得到了一个无法被超越的成绩。两步就猜出来了。这家伙。还不错。是的。还不错。听起来太棒了。
But it's so exciting. Also just all the emails you get from people, because I think, yeah, bits or free. You can give them away the world. And AI is sounds fancy, but it's just code. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, listen, I want you with a fresh mind tomorrow when you get back at it, so I don't want you to stay up later any more today. Thank you for joining us.
但这太令人兴奋了。还有人们发给你的所有邮件，因为我觉得，是的，这些比特信息是免费的。你可以把它们送给全世界。人工智能听起来很高级，但它其实只是代码。对，对，对。好吧，听着，我希望你明天带着清醒的头脑重新投入工作，所以我不想让你今天再熬夜了。谢谢你加入我们。
Do you guys feel a little smarter? Yes, I do. A little bit smarter. I feel smarter. I definitely do. Please say thank you to Max. Thank you. Thank you.
你们觉得自己变聪明了一点吗？是的，我有这种感觉。聪明了一点点。我觉得自己变聪明了。我绝对有这种感觉。请对马克斯说谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。
Thank you very, very much, buddy. Here, pal. Thank you very much. Thank you. Max. Thank you, Max. Thank you, Max. Woo. Woo.
非常非常感谢你，老兄。给，伙计。非常感谢。谢谢。马克斯。谢谢你，马克斯。谢谢你，马克斯。呜。呜。
Now here's the thing. Now, how much? I, go ahead. How much dumber do you think you are than him? Like, on an IQ score, what do you think his score is versus yours? He reminded me how much smarter I am than you, which was great. That's fair. Do you think it's actually, I feel, very void by that whole experience?
现在问题来了。那么，多少？我，请说。你觉得自己比他笨多少？比如，在智商分数上，你觉得他的分数和你的相比怎么样？他提醒了我，我比你聪明多少，这太棒了。这倒挺公平。你觉得实际上，我真的被整个经历深深地鼓舞了吗？
Do you think it's double, his until the top of the turn? Double your, his, over mine? Over mine. Actually, I feel very boyd by that whole experience. Do you think it's double? His and tell the truth? Double your mind? His overmind? Overmind. Oh, easily. No, no, no, no. I mean, he's just, he has a very big brain.
你觉得这是双重的吗？一直到转弯的顶端？双倍你的，他的，超过我的？超过我的。其实，我对整个经历感到非常振奋。你觉得是双重的吗？他说的是实话吗？双倍你的思维？他的超思维？超思维。哦，绝对是。不，不，不，不。我的意思是，他只是，他有一个非常大的大脑。
I could talk to him for hours. I don't know that he would listen to me for more than five minutes, but I could talk to him for hours. Yeah. I love all of the fantastic guests. Yeah. Right up my alley. Right up my alley. Very cool. And I think that if I think that if we all spent more time thinking about that kind of stuff just a little bit that
我可以跟他聊几个小时。我不知道他是否会听我讲超过五分钟，但我可以跟他聊几个小时。是的。我喜欢所有这些极好的嘉宾。是的。正合我意。正合我意。太酷了。而且我认为，如果我们大家花更多的时间去思考那种事情，哪怕只是一点点
maybe we could get around to solving some big issues tonight. Let's solve it tonight guys. Everybody, let it up. Yeah, I'm so cool. Thank you. I know you. We all kind of share. We love all of our guests. Those are nice pops because there's stuff that we don't usually cover on the podcast. And I've just repeating myself, but I just love that stuff. I could ask him a million more questions.
也许我们今晚就能解决一些大问题。今晚就解决它吧，伙计们。大家，加油。是的，我太酷了。谢谢你们。我懂你们。我们都有点共同点。我们喜欢所有的嘉宾。这些都是很好的爆料，因为有些东西是我们平时在播客里不会涉及的。我可能在重复自己，但我就是喜欢这些内容。我还可以问他一百万个问题。
Well, it's the original conceit of this thing, air go the title. We thought we'd bring people on that can educate us a little bit more on things that we don't know about. We happen to get lazy and ask some of our famous fancy friends to come on. This is a real treat to be able to access these big, big thinkers in this incredible town. So, thanks for having me.
嗯，这是这东西最初的构思，由此得名标题。我们原以为我们会请一些人来，能让我们更多地了解我们所不知道的事情。我们碰巧偷懒，请了一些我们著名的花哨朋友来。能够在这个不可思议的镇上接触到这些伟大的思想家，真是一种享受。所以，谢谢你们邀请我。
And now, it's incumbent upon us to really kind of do something about it. We can't sit around all day in our pajamas, you know, and in our slippers, you know what I mean? Or then just go to the golf course and then get in our test list. We have to.
现在，我们有责任真正对此做点什么。我们不能整天穿着睡衣坐在那儿，你知道的，穿着拖鞋，你懂我的意思吗？或者然后去高尔夫球场，然后坐上我们的特斯拉。我们必须这样做。
Do you think that's important for, and I don't want to single anybody. I will never be one of those people. The ruining things. But no, it is true that thank you for you've educated us a little bit more. It's pretty bad. And I think, you know, I could talk to them. I want to talk to them about the web telescope
你认为这对外边的人重要吗，我不想单独针对任何人。我绝不会成为那种人。毁掉事情的人。但是不，确实如此，谢谢你，你让我们学到了更多。这挺糟糕的。而且我认为，你知道的，我可以跟他们谈。我想跟他们谈谈韦伯望远镜
because, you know, those kinds of things. Oh god, here comes a buy, everybody. Get you feel it when it starts to ramp up the engine. Sean, if you don't land it, you can't do it. No, you just gotta get into it more subtly. Well, I'm just saying you a mile ahead. I'm just saying like telescope, like that is much better than any thing like this.
因为，你知道，那种事情。哦天哪，有买家来了，大家。当引擎开始加速时，你能感觉到。肖恩，如果你不着陆，你就做不到。不，你只是得更巧妙地切入。好吧，我的意思是，你领先一英里。我的意思是，像望远镜这样的东西，比任何类似的东西都要好得多。
What are these call, all those are, are you scared? Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, boss, and thank you so much. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
这些叫什么，所有那些是，你害怕吗？嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，老板，非常感谢。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armstrong, and Bennett Barberco. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。《SmartLess》由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆斯特朗和班尼特·巴伯科100%有机纯手工制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。